okay students settle down settle down
that includes you mr. Rodriguez do you
want to take the milk carton off of your
head thank you so much we have a special
guest today he's from this neighborhood
and he's a former gang member he's
coming here this morning to talk to you
about life choices
so please give a warm Central High
School welcome to Donnie Herrera I used
to be just like you just like you you
you you used to clown around make fun of
the principal but milk on my head just
like you Rodriguez and then I got hit
with AIDS consequences
got into some real trouble boy
[Music]
stole from my mom and dad stole from my
own sister and then one day a piano fell
on my head what consequences
give me 88 concussions one for each key
you think I'm learning but no see I'm
just like you I got back out there
started making some real crimes homeboy
oh yeah oh yeah and then I got trampled
by a herd of buffalo what concert Glenn
says okay Donny um I think we've had
enough done what my story I was like you
I decided he'd be cool to hang out with
some of the tough kids mm-hmm you know
who I'm talking about
they were hanging on the streets late at
night more than cigarette smokers homes
and then one day I got shot out of a
catapult that's it
into the mouth of a dragon students
everything you've heard here today is
alive I don't lie anymore you're all
excused look at me I shouldn't even be
here
but a gesture is so I got really deep in
the crime I did a drive-by at my own
daughters quinceañera yeah shut up
everybody
dad tell ya then I got sucked into a
wormhole consequences that's it okay
everybody go I was in another dimension
time to introduce my own parents to each
other almost failed arm was disappearing
I
vintage Johnny be good and my fear is
prom and at the last moment they kissed
and it came back faster we get away from
him the better but nobody believed me we
make Gregg really great
you